let me give you a little plug on
medicated pete show because a lot of
people are asking me what is this show
going to be
for those of you who don't know he was
he interned for us and uh honestly we in
we had him
intern because he was so funny it wasn't
like he did anything right ronnie he
just stood around on the halls
right and then yeah you know he used to
stand over john hein's shoulder all the
time and bothered the [ __ ] out of him
yeah yeah
yeah anyway medicated pete his dream is
to be in show business
yeah but he's got tourette's and he's
got all kinds of things
and uh right yeah and he's
he's low on talent let's put it that way
so we thought pete would be an
interesting talk show host and we gave
him an audition
and we told him to come up with all the
ideas you know come up with music come
up with segments and all this stuff
we even booked him a real life celebrity
the rapper and actor ice-t
we gave pete a month to prepare for the
interview but just a few days before the
interview pete
barely had prepped at all yeah and jump
out the chance
yeah i know uh at five so finally it's
time for the big interview
and things got off to a rough start live
from mom's kitchen
is what are your interests with medicare
[Music]
on today's show medicare repeat welcomes
rapper and
[Music]
and now
what up everybody what's going on here
this is medicated peter what's your
interest man
iced tea what's up brother
what's up pete how you doing man what
are your interests buddy
what's up hey man i'm just hanging man
just just ready to talk to you that's
what i'm interested in what's going on
man
it's good good to see you good to see
you yes what's up brother
he just kept asking ice tea like
variations on the same question what's
up this went on for
how long why not oh my god pete
instead of asking iced tea question goes
hey i want to be an actor let's
improvise the scene
we're talking about your movie here
equal standard man um
great movie i i got a chance to see it a
couple times
um so listen i'm an inspiring actor so
uh let's create a little scene here real
quick you're the good cop
i'm gonna be the criminal sitting on the
table okay so you're gonna
be uh you're gonna kind of like
interrogating me a little bit here
so all right let's start let's try to
get a little scene going together here
so uh well let's go pete there's no
sense in you even trying to lie to me
you look like a rapist you act like a
rapist
you rape that girl i i i
stop lying just tell the truth i i
i just don't know what to say man i i
say the truth before i come over there
and smack the [ __ ] out of you i
i i i just don't know what to say
why'd you do it i don't know it was
i was under pressure i feel under
pressure
i i don't know what to say i got it one
line for
acting and one line for interviewing
that iced tea he's so good he scared the
[ __ ] at me i would have admitted to the
rape right away
that's it put me in jail yeah well you
gotta say pete didn't back down
he just still didn't know what to say he
goes i don't know what to say
[Laughter]
then like i guess pete didn't know what
to do anymore so his mom got on mike
oh really because she's evidently a huge
iced tea
fan like you've seen everything yeah but
then and then pete got jealous and
kicked his mom off the show
iced tea hi mom i'm happy to meet you
it's a privilege
thank you so much for taking the time we
love you here
we've been following you since the 90s
your music my girls got into
iced tea loves cocoa yes law and order
and now we watched equal standard
and we loved it the message that you
uh sent i i'm shaking right now you have
no idea
okay okay thank you so much iced tea i
appreciate
it so much thank you bye thank you i
love you iced tea
bye medicated pete's mom hey you got a
nice mom pete nice too
sorry man she just rambles on
[Laughter]
she did more prep than he did oh my
goodness she
rambles on sorry iced tea my mom isn't
good at talking like we both are
you know he thinks he's conducting a
fine show
yeah yeah he had to get back to nothing
like he had been there
nothing was happening so we had to cut
it off like we just had to stop the show
so iced tea could get going you know
what i mean
the guy was being held prisoner hey so i
quickly i
i did i did go to acting school so i i
studied uh meisner's
which was a cool acting technique
because it because
it just made it more made it made it
more real
i guess all right pete all right pete
that's all the time we have so
you got about 30 seconds to wrap it up
but um iced tea man
thank you again man thank you again
brother for coming on taking us taking
this time
it sounds like iced tea had already left
i know yeah he was gone
he was blinking out morse code get me
the [ __ ] off this thing